good morning and most welcome to the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences and
this press conference about the Prize in
Economic Sciences we will present it
both in Swedish and in English and
you're welcome to ask questions in
either language welcome nautical Navy
intense cop soccer I mean the docks
additionally various leagues banks
priests economics Kristin Scott till
alfred bells mean he could be pre
sitting stiff status Nitin on the sixth
ops very six banco de las you worried
for for CUNY on the gongmin preset Venus
iris or expansion when they come we have
a tense cops Academy some serious talk
from the professor pastor very good for
Andy please comedian professor peter
yard enforce lead amount of this
committee will help you rank on Sun
Academy's standard security area the
very six Bank Prize in Economic Sciences
in memory of Alfred Nobel was
established in 1968 by this various
Riksbank the central bank of Sweden and
it is awarded by the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences now for the 49th
time I am your on Hansen I'm the
secretary-general of the Academy on my
right is Professor pesterin by chairman
of the Prize Committee on my left
professor peter yard enforce also a
member of the committee this year's
prize is about understanding the
psychology of economics Horace please
hang on at first Oh sooo cool again
he economy Kolya Vietnam cops Academy
enormously that tella various tricks
banks prissy economics Phaeton's cop
till alfred nobel's mean thorough
geographer on till Richard ho failure
for us be drug til billion the economy
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has decided to award this various
Riksbank prize in Economic Sciences in
memory of Alfred Nobel to Richard H
failure for his contributions to
behavioral economics and you see the
photo of dr. Thaler on the screen above
us he was born in 1945 in New Jersey in
the United States he got his PhD at the
University of Rochester and he's
currently professor of behavioral
science and economics at the University
of Chicago he is the US citizen and
after that announcement the chairman of
the prize committee pastor and I will
give us some introductory remarks about
the research and the low rate of the
price thank you
economists are a lot about trying to
understand how people make economic
decisions and behave when they interact
in markets now the problem is that human
behavior is very complex so if we want
to construct useful models of economic
behavior we have to make simplifications
one such simplification which has been
very important in economics is the
assumption that humans behave in a fully
rational way and make economics
decisions to maximize their own
well-being this simplification has been
incredibly powerful and has helped
economists construct models to analyze a
large number of important economic
phenomena now it's not that economists
believe everyone is rational but the
issue is that whether the deviations
from rationality are important enough
and systematic enough to really affect
economic outcomes in an important way
now over time researchers gather more
and more evidence on how human
psychology actually deviates from this
fully rational model
and Richard Saylor is a pioneer when it
comes to incorporating such insights
from psychology into economic analysis
for last four decades he has used both
theories and conceptual models lab
experiments empirical tests and surveys
to document and analyze how specific
aspects of human psychology
systematically shape economic decisions
Richard Saylor's findings have inspired
many other researchers coming in his
footsteps and it has paved the way for a
new field in economics which we call
behavioral economics and thanks to his
contributions and discoveries this new
field has gone from being sort of a
fringe and somewhat controversial part
of economics to being a mainstream area
of contemporary economic research and
insights from behavioral economics has
not only been important for academic
economic research but has increasingly
been applied to design better economic
policy Thank You Pat and now p3r de
force will give us some more insights
into this area and the discoveries that
led to the price better the floor is
yours
with Richard Taylor is a pioneer in
integrating economics and psychology
he's analyzed three ways in which humans
systematically deviate from the
traditional economic models first even
if we try to make rational decisions we
have limited cognitive abilities our
rationality is bounded second even if
our if they're even though our decisions
are often guided by self-interest we
also have social preferences and we care
about fairness and equity and third we
sometimes soccer suffer from lack of
self control I will now present some of
Taylor's contributions to each of these
areas first is bounded rationality
Taylor has proposed a theory of mental
accounting it builds on the observation
that most people in their minds group
their payments into different accounts
housing
food vacation and so on many of you have
a credit card and your account for the
card has a high interest rate at the
same time you may have a savings account
for a future vacation for a new
apartment that has a low interest rate
this may seem irrational since money
from a low interest savings account may
be used to pay off the depths on the
high interest credit card account but
you're afraid that if you take out money
from your savings account you will not
put it back so having a credit card
account is a way of preventing your from
excessive spending and in this way we
can exercise self-control and commit
ourselves to spending less by keeping
separate mental accounts mental accounts
have boundaries over time they can be
opened and they are closed so for
example buying a stock can be seen as
opening a new account with the purchase
price as some kind of reference level if
a stock gains in value it's easy to sell
it and close the account but people are
aversive to losses so if a stock losses
in value investors tend to wait for the
value to get back to the purchase level
at least and they therefore hold on to
losing stocks longer than it's
economically rational the second area is
social preferences in many situations
socially oriented motivations such as
such as a desire for fairness are
important and in joint experimental work
with his colleagues failure has shown
her judgments about fairness play role
in economic decisions a simple example
is a store that normally sell umbrellas
for $10 but raises the price to $20 or
even more during heavy rain so if
consumers take the normal price to
as a reference point that will regard
this as unfair pricing and such
reactions may influence the pricing
policy of the company
similarly someone earning 20 dollars an
hour working in a company typically uses
this as a reference wage if the company
in a recession proposes to cut the wage
from $20 to 15 this will be considered
unfair by the employees such fairness
judgments explain the relative stability
of wage levels even in in bad times the
third area is limited self control we
all live with a conflict between our
desires for the present and our hopes
for the future a classical example is
Odysseus who is torn between his desire
to go to the sirens and his future plans
such a conflict may lead us to deviate
from our long-term plans so when you're
30 you may decide to start saving for
your retirement when you are 35 but when
you turn 35 you may change your mind and
keep up your consumption rather than
start saving as previously planned
together with his colleagues failure has
divided what is called the planner do a
model for how this conflict can be
handled the planner is concerned with
the well-being in long run while the
doer only concerns the current is only
concerned about the current well-being
so to resolve the conflict the planner
can either force the doer to do
something by exercising costly willpower
or impose rules that limit the range of
the Duras choices justice odysseus did
when he tied himself to the most common
examples of such rules are don't keep
alcohol at home only buy one cigarette
pack of cigarettes at a time or don't
buy food when you're when you're hungry
the plan of dual model captures
the idea that what can one can resist
temptation at the cost to the psyche
similar dual system models of
decision-making have later been applied
and studied in psychology and in
neuroscience
I finally turn to applications of the
economic models failure has together
with his colleagues advocated what they
call libertarian paternalism and the
idea is to design policies that nudge
people to into making better decisions
for themselves
for example failure has devised a
nudging mechanism for pension savings
called saved more tomorrow in the
program an individual commits to
allocating a share of future salary
increases to savings this policy helps
people exercise more self-control an
important aspect is that the
participants can opt out of the program
at any time but in reality very few
decide to opt out the same moral program
same or tomorrow program has been
successful since it has substantially
increased pension savings so to sum up
taylor has given us new insights into
how human psychology shapes decision
making he has devised new experimental
tools to investigate human behavior his
research has spawned a new field
behavioral economics and he's shown how
policy is based on insights from this
field can he'll help people make better
decisions he's made economics more human
thank you thank you very much Peter that
great introduction and now we may have
dr. sailor with us on the phone he's on
his way to the phone at least not yet
while we're waiting questions to the
panel
anybody who's brave enough to ask one of
my colleagues here a question we
prepared for a lot of questions so don't
be shy
don't hesitate you had all expected this
price of course dr. Taylor yes hello
hello hello dr. Taylor this is Joe Ron
Hansen the guy who woke you up an hour
ago
good morning yarn good morning
have you had your cup of coffee now
great so we're here in the session Hall
of the Royal Academy of Sciences with
the journalist from Sweden and and all
over the world and and I'm sure they are
eager to ask you questions I hope they
have it also had their cups of coffee so
they should be prepared to ask some
questions who would like to start please
now we didn't hear there was something
wrong with the connections for for a
second or two could you repeat the
answer please I think the most important
lesson try to repeat the question that
we see if we can hear the most important
in yes so I think the most important
impact is the recognition that economic
agents are human and economic model
to incorporate that yes the lady over
there hello Jenny Peterson from titi
news agency what was your first thought
when you got the call this morning well
I was pleased I no longer will have to
call my golf buddy gene fama professor
Palmer on the golf course yeah he was
here a few years ago wasn't he Yeah
right you have a question over there hi
this is yeah it's Nordstrom from tv4 in
Stockholm Sweden first congratulations
mr. thaller on the price thank you I'm
wondering I seem to recall you had a
short Hollywood career in the movie The
Big Short you explain the hot hand
fallacy about how somebody who is
successful in something is assumed to be
successful going on I'm wondering if
that applies to the current American
president mr. Trump well I do think that
the film career is probably was
important to the awarding of this prize
I was I was disappointed it wasn't part
of the of the official speech as to
President Trump I think he would do well
to watch that movie I'm also wondering
there's a substantial amount of money
involved here in the price.you nine
million Swedish Krona roundabouts I'm
wondering if you're going to be super
rational about this money or if you will
act humanely and in what way will act
humanely with the money in that case
well you know this is actually quite a
funny question because as the as the
citation noted one of my fields of
research
what's called mental accounting and
according to standard economic theory
there's no way of knowing which money
gets spent on what so if I put my good
Chicago economist hat on then I can't
answer your question but but but
[Laughter]
congratulations professor Taylor and
this is efficient access zone from
freelance for China radio and
in post I just wonder you
know in your research did you touch upon
the Chinese economy because Chinese
economy was very much influenced by the
Chicago School thoughts I think and in
your opinion what's your prediction
about Chinese economy in five years say
thank you I'm sorry I have no expertise
at all on the Chinese economy except
that it's growing very rapidly but I
have not no insight sorry okay we have a
question over there yes please sailor I
had the opportunity to listen to a stock
term recently when you were talking
about the pension system in Sweden do
you think that your policy advice will
have more impact now when you have I
don't know whether the Swedish
parliament how they think about use
Nobel Prize winners but I hope they they
listened to the research I presented
them the additional research that
my colleagues and I are doing because I
think there are a way to improve the
Swedish pension system hey we need that
please professor
there are congratulations this is
evening full from China's national
Xinhua news agency
my question is you obviously opened the
door for the the research on economics
and psychology so I wonder in the future
what will your research direction go and
in which specific areas would your
research results be applied to thank you
well I've never been one to plan my
research very far in advance but as the
previous question are indicated I've
recently been studying of all things the
Swedish pension system and the choice
architecture of that system and my
colleagues and I are working on the
paper on that right now the tentative
title is nudges are forever
okay I think we've pretty much covered
the the questions that were raised here
and so dr. Taylor thank you very much
for being with us at this press
conference and we look forward very much
indeed to welcoming you to Stockholm in
December and I for one could could
benefit from some advice about my own
private pension system thank you very
much thank you thank you very much I
look forward to seeing you all in
December thank you bye-bye all right now
have you thought of any questions to the
panel or is everything crystal clear I
guess you're all waiting for the AH
there is a gentleman over there yes
please yes David Keaton Associated Press
um so this is the second year in a row
where there
no female winners amongst all the prizes
and several years now that there have
been no female winners for this specific
prize
do you have an insight in why this may
be and second second part could you tell
me a little bit about more about the
decision-making process how many women
are on the panel that decide this and is
it fairly representative in your opinion
okay I'll start and give you the general
figures for all the prices and then
first remember you can comment more
specifically about the Prize in Economic
Sciences the we are very proud of the
laureates who are awarded this year and
one of those last year and so forth but
we are disappointed looking at in a
larger perspective that there aren't
more women who have been awarded part of
it is of course that we go back in time
to identify the discoveries you we have
to wait until they have been verified
and validated before we can award the
prize and they were an even a larger
bias against women in terms of fewer
female scientists if you go back 20 or
30 years but I'm not sure that's the
entire explanation we have taken
measures we and the other prize-awarding
institutions if you look at the
committee is now the Nobel committees
there are women chairing actually three
of the six committees there are female
scientists or equivalent on all the
committees so I don't I don't think
there is an as any substantial male
chauvinist bias in the committees and we
are also the committees have invited
taken special effort to identify women
scientists to start not to nominate for
the prize
to a greater extent but it sorted this
year because we are concerned that we
may not get enough nominations of female
scientists we don't this we don't
nominate ourselves we invite nominations
from the scientific community in the
world and I suspect that there are many
more women who are deserving to be
considered for the prize and therefore
we have started to identify specifically
leading thin women scientists and I
invite them to nominate we will starting
next year indicate in our invitations to
nominate and as asked the nominators to
identify women scientists and also
consider ethnic diversity geographic
diversity and finally we are going to
going to have a conference this winter
with the different price committees to
discuss this issue so we are concerned
we have are taking measures I hope that
in five years ten years we'll see a very
different distribution and that's the
situation as of now Pat what's your
comment regarding economic sciences
specifically yeah I can just underscore
what you said I think there are two
important points one is that we are
indeed awarding research that where the
discoveries were made let's say in the
70s 80s maybe early 90s during a time
when when we had much more of a gender
bias and economics as well as in other
many other sciences which basically
means that as time goes by the fraction
of female or it's will increase I'm
certain of that and you can look at some
of the prices that are given to more to
younger economists you know some of the
top prices there the gender distribution
is much more even and the second thing
is that that said this is something that
we are very concerned about
and what you have to realize is that the
committee doesn't just freely decide on
these prices we aggregate the opinion of
you know nominators all over the world
and we're very reliant on their
nominations so if there's anything we
can do I guess it's a call for the
nominating body to to also take these
issues more seriously so consider this
and request to all our nominators for
all the prices to consider also women
scientists who have made important
contributions please I just like to ask
any of you who can comment because when
we have the Nobel Prize in medicine
people understand as that okay there to
give us a good message that we should
not work too late and then in this
economic price my understanding is that
people should be rational and don't
spend or or maybe save your money for
pension little bit earlier or at a
reasonable time and the quantity is my
understanding okay that yeah yes I mean
that's a fair description I mean what
distinguishes failures models from
others is this it brings out this
conflict between our desires for the
present and our plans for the future and
in retrospect we sometimes regret what
we've done last night or last year so
this he has devised methods for us to
his told us how to nudge ourselves to be
apply more self-control and in for
example in terms of saving but there are
many other application areas as well
more questions last final question
please my name is you wanna shake from
long snoot area I wonder about issues a
like getting the price alone I mean if
you look back yeah most years the price
has been shared between different
candidates
and two or three ones but this one is
only one and does that mean that his
contribution is so unique or does it
mean that yes we've been working or what
is the explanation well this is I guess
Andy she's not completely easy to answer
but I mean when we when we work through
these these prices in these areas that
we want to award we try to find the
people that are you know most
responsible for the particular area that
we want to to give the award to
sometimes it's a very natural group of
people as you know we can give award the
price up to three candidates but other
times there is a clear person who is
behind the area that we want to award
and I in this particular case it was
clear to us that that a solo prize to
Richard sailor was the natural one now
there are many researchers following in
his footsteps and you know so one should
not be surprised if if other people in
this strand later on we'll also get
recognized but who knows okay I think
we'll close there those of you are
requested individual interviews we'll be
able to do them right after this thank
you very much for your interest
[Applause]
today I'm done for the prices in
behavioral economics
can you explain what it is behavioral
economics means that you take into
account human psychological factors such
as our limited rationality our social
concerns we care about the well-being of
others as well and also our lack of
self-control these are the three main
factors that are accounted for him in
the behavioral economics and what are
the main the major contributions from
this year's prize Laura
he has worked in all three areas and
made groundbreaking proposals and also a
lot of experiments in the areas that
have shown the economic consequences of
of these human factors you can call that
man so there is proposed theories in all
three areas for more economical system
is used called the rational almost no
even even though Richard Thaler is from
Chicago he doesn't belong to the Chicago
School in her scream one of the main
proponents for Homo economicus but he
has really wanted to show that humans
the fact the human factors really has an
influence on economic decisions the
earlier models has thought of these
shortcoming as being kind of random
deviations and and not really if you are
irrational you will boost soon be thrown
out of the market but he shown that this
is not true these there are systematic
deviations in human behavior that needs
to be explained they explain yes so do
you have any examples of those
systematic they diversions one is this
model of of mental accounting I mean we
tend to keep our spendings in different
boxes so to speak and
for additional economic theory says that
it doesn't matter where you put your
money you should be able to move it
between these boxes but people don't I
mean they have savings accounts for for
vacation that have one count for buying
a new car and so on and I don't want to
spend money from one account to use in
another to pay off your credit card debt
for instance
so that's one example this is
experimental science yeah he's also done
lots of experiments in particular when
it comes to our judgments of fairness
there is together with the earlier
laureate Daniel Kahneman he has done a
series of experiments in all involving
several games ultimatum game they take
their games so-called that showed that
people really care about the being fair
to others in wage wages for instance
that people are not willing to be unfair
in wages they don't like when a company
raises the price of a product if demand
suddenly rises they think that there is
a fair price for a product and even if
the company could sell the the product
at the higher price they don't think I
should so it's not a fair price that's
another area talked about US tradition
and economic systems we all only think
about our own self-interest of course
you can say that our being fair being
just to you is good for me in the long
run so some economists say that this can
be modeled but failure has shown that
there are more concerns and it's more
it's more general than has before before
and he's provided experimental evidence
for that side and his colleague the
dimensions Daniel Kahneman
it's also a previous price lurid they
work together and he also wrote a book
about thinking fast or slow so what does
Richard Taylor say about that yeah their
relation is is very interesting because
failure worked with Kahneman in the
early 1980s and he was inspired by
Kahneman and versus prospect theory when
he developed to the theory mental
accounting for instance or the fear of
the endowment effect is not always
contributions but then he also developed
this planner do a model that is used to
explain how we are not so good at saving
for our future well-being and actually
Daniel Kahneman has then later taken up
this model so when he talks about
Thinking Fast and thinking slow this is
an example of such a planner and doer
model immediately the first one is the
one who lives in the present and the
slow one is the one who lives for from
the for the long perspective so one can
say that Kahneman has been inspired by
famous modern models that there is a
given and a take between these two price
we have this thinking about people like
about delayed rewards it is not new
is it new for economists the
psychological factors are not new I mean
they are all well known I mean this
bounded rationality limited self-control
and so on they're well known
psychological what Thaler has done is to
put this into a economic context and
shown that it has large consequences for
economic decisions and he has also been
able to model some of these consequences
so it's not the psychological factors as
such but it's their impact on on
economic theory she also has coined a
new term nudging can you explain it
nudging means that that you want to help
people to do something that I like
themselves and that's very important
they learn doesn't want to be pretty
paternalist he doesn't want to impose
rules on on people he want to be a he
wants to be a Liberty
arian paternalist that means that you
should always keep the freedom of the
individual but you can still device
certain mechanism to help the people
plan better for the future and his most
well-known examples of nudging of his
pension saving programs they save more
tomorrow why why did this you could you
could ask yourself if nudging is also a
kind of manipulation
that's the has been criticism against
his nudging yeah but the criticize
has often missed this fact that a person
can always opt out of the program if he
or she wants to it's not there you're
not bouncing you can always leave a
pension saving program or you can always
change your mind concerning being an
organ donator or something like that so
it's it's a libertarian program so it's
you're not imposing anything on prices
in his logic so in what way would you
say retailer has changed the economical
science well the short summaries that he
has made economics more human say when
you call him this morning
hey he was slow to wake up I must say I
think he was it was not prepared for it
it was happy of course yes yes he was
happy but he was quite taken by that I
was my impression
thank you very much
you